you well tonight is the night battle for
vegas 2022 it is here rocky stop by the
ballpark to give us a preview
we are here at the beautiful las vegas
ballpark in summerlin and it it's empty
right now okay but james what is it
going to look like in a few hours so
tonight should be a packed house should
have almost 8 000 people here for a
charity softball game featuring team
riley versus team josh jacobs we'll talk
about those teams later on in the show
we'll talk about who's going to be on
the teams but first and foremost let's
discuss why you brought this to the
community you're one of the co-founders
of battle for vegas yeah so riley smith
is a client of ours and um back when we
started representing him in 2019
it was his passion and desire to create
a charity event that gives back to the
community that's been so good to him and
his family and then has welcomed him and
his teammates to las vegas so las vegas
is obviously home for him he's just
signed an extension and every year you
know he did an interview last week and
he said this is his favorite day of the
year oh i love it well i'm sure it is
his opposing team's favorite day of the
year as well they have so much fun um
tell me about you know
how it's grown over the years last year
to this year
yeah each year i mean you know our goal
every year is to raise more money for
charity um this year there's two charity
partners each year we pick two different
partners okay so the two uh charity
beneficiaries one is communities in
school and then the other one is a
charity called maximum home which is the
foundation founded by comedian brad
garrett that's awesome and what's the
rundown
you know starting around what six
o'clock yeah so gates open at 5 30. okay
uh the home run derby starts at 6 30. uh
game assault starts at 7 30 and then
there's fireworks at in the game at nine
o'clock wow so this is a full this is a
packed full evening for the entire
family yeah we always say it's a great
family fun event i mean there's
something for everyone the softball game
obviously is part of it but there's so
much other things going on we've got all
the mascots here
buckets from the aces will be here uh
cash from the aces will be here so we've
got all the mascots everyone's here it's
a family fun event and last but
certainly not least you have something
very special that separates you from any
charity baseball game in the world i'm
gonna say
what is that we have uh four f-35 jets
that will do a flyover here um just
before uh just before the first pitch so
i think we're the only softball game in
the country that has a flyover from the
air force base that is so cool the whole
family come on down where do you get
tickets because there's still tickets
available there's still tickets
available you can get tickets at the
ballpark here you can get them at
battleforvegas.com or you can get them
ticketmaster.com alright so coming up
later in the show we're going to talk
about who is on the two teams that are
battling out tonight at the las vegas
ball podcast back to you guys